students around the world are skipping
school today and taking to the streets
to protest global warming demonstrations
in Madrid Tokyo and Melbourne Australia
are being billed as a global day of
action ahead of climate change meetings
beginning in Madrid next month
MTS tyub is with the protesters in
London's Parliament Square good morning
we're here outside the Prime Minister's
house where young people from across
Britain have left school to take to the
streets to protest against climate
change
ahead of a major UN summit in Spain
saying they want their politicians in
the UK to make climate change a key
focus of next month's general election
the first protests of the day was in
Sydney Australia where more than a
hundred and fifty wildfires are still
burning across the country that has left
more than 5 million people in the city
struggling under a toxic cloud these
strikes are part of the global movement
started last year by Swedish schoolgirl
Gretna tunberg since then millions of
people from around the world have joined
the effort to raise the alarm now the UN
has warned this week that countries need
to dramatically cut back on their
greenhouse gases or faced with their
calling climate chaos Eureka MTM taya
force in London thank you